you don't endorse a lot of candidates on
the show or get even too close to
politicians because honestly most of
them are really disappointing they say
they're going to do one thing they do
another but occasionally run to somebody
who could actually change things
and you know that person could change
things because all the right people are
hysterical literally hysterical about
the idea of him advancing to the united
states senate that would be jd vance and
he's running for senate from ohio the
primary is tomorrow and we thought it
would be nice to talk to him on the eve
of that jd vance thanks a lot for coming
on tonight congrats on the poll numbers
showing you ahead but i still thought
it'd be worth hearing you explain why
you want to be in the senate what you do
if you get there
well tucker simply i'd fight for normal
people because i think for so long in
the republican party we've sent people
that represented the donors or the other
special interests in our country
the corporate class that's for example
forcing pharmaceutical companies to give
hormonal therapies to children those
people have a voice in washington dc but
normal people don't and if i could say
tucker i think that what's at stake in
this election in this primary in
particular is what kind of republican
party will we have will we have the old
republican party that started started
stupid foreign wars that shipped
american manufacturing base to china
and that didn't actually defend
america's cultural values or are we
going to have a republican party that
fights for our own voters that protects
the jobs of the american manufacturing
manufacturing sector and that fights
back against these stupid foreign
misadventures that's really what's on
the table tomorrow i feel confident that
ohio voters are going to choose me
because at the end of the day they don't
want to go backwards they want a
republican party that actually stands
for americans first
i don't even need to hear a word of your
pitch to know you're the guy because i
know for a fact there are a lot of
republican senators in washington who
are terrified by the idea of you getting
there are you aware of that
i'm certainly aware of it tucker in fact
if you live in ohio you've seen 20
million dollars close to that of
negative advertising almost all of it
focused against me
uh interestingly enough the same
organizations that are trying to take me
down in 2022 are the same groups that
try to take trump down in 2016. it's
actually the exact same pro-china
anti-american organizations uh so i'm
certainly aware of it tucker but the end
of the day these are the fights that are
worth having uh the people who have
profited from the managed decline of
this country they're not going to give
all up their power and their money
easily but these are the fights that are
ultimately worth having the fact that
they're coming after me lets me know i'm
doing something right and hopefully the
people of ohio see that i'm doing
something right as well they can tell
you're sincere and they're very upset
about this is an exciting race and we'll
be watching carefully jd vance good luck
tomorrow thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight